YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Imagine this scenario.
You're running an
analytics workload
in Google Cloud that reads
data from Google Cloud Storage
and processes it
using a Dataflow job.
The amount of data that the
job processes has been growing,
but your pipeline hasn't
had any issues keeping up.
You're having lunch when you
get an alert on your phone.
Your pipeline is returning
processing errors.
You abandon your lunch,
open your laptop,
and start investigating.
Sure enough, the
Dataflow job is failing.
And it turns out that
Cloud Storage requests
are resulting in 429 Too
Many Requests errors.
This has never happened before.
What could be going on?
Well, it's possible
you've exhausted
a quota in your project, and
the job is being throttled.
My name is Yuri.
And I'm a site reliability
engineer at Google.
Today I'm going to show you
how to proactively monitor
quotas and get notified when you
start to approach the limit so
that you can raise the quota and
avoid problems like this one.
Welcome to "Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, let's dig into
this and figure out
if the errors you are
seeing are actually
due to running out of quota.
We can start on the Quotas page.
Here we can see that we've run
out of Egress bandwidth quota
in this region.
Let's go to the Products menu
and select Metrics Explorer
under Monitoring.
Here we can plot quota usage
against quota limit over time.
Both of these metrics are
available for the Consumer
Quota resource.
The usage metric is
called rate quota usage.
Rate quotas are typically
used for limiting
the number of requests you
can make to an API or service
and are applied over a
specific time interval.
In this case, the quota is
Egress bandwidth per second.
The other kind of quota
is an allocation quota,
which restricts how
many resources you
can have provisioned at a
time, such as the number
of VMs in a project.
They reset when the resources
are released, when the VMs are
deleted, for example.
The other metric we need here
is the quota limit metric,
which tells us what the
limit for this rate usage is.
There's another way
to view this data.
We can use MQL, the
Monitoring Query Language,
to actually calculate a ratio
of quota usage to quota limit.
We'll post a link for this
query in the episode notes.
Here we clearly see that
our usage to limit ratio
exceeded 1 for a period of time.
This explains why our
job was throttled.
So now we know that we did
exhaust network Egress quota.
And that's why our job got
throttled and started failing.
We submitted a quota
increase request
which unblocked our job.
Our pipeline is
back up and running.
We don't want this to
keep happening, right?
Let's set up an alert
that will notify us
if we get close to the
new increased quota.
Let's start on the
Alerting screen
and create a new
alerting policy.
We'll use MQL to
define this policy.
Paste the query here.
And run it to evaluate
both the query
we've written to calculate
the usage-limit ratio
and the threshold for
that ratio that we want
to use to trigger the alert.
That threshold is defined
here, in the last statement
in the query, using a
condition statement.
Looks like our
signal is correct.
We need to name our condition.
And specify how we
want to be notified
the next time the alert fires.
We also want to specify
whether the incident should
be automatically closed after
some amount of time passes.
Let's name the alert.
And review the
policy to validate
that we've defined our signal
and threshold correctly.
And I think we did.
And that's how you can use
MQL to calculate the usage
to limit ratio and
set up alerting
to be notified when you
start approaching a quota
limit in your project.
Great.
Now, if we start to
get close to the quota,
we'll get an alert so
we can avoid having
our job be throttled again.
That's engineering
for reliability.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more "Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud."
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]